[Music]
how would the world change if all of a
sudden
every biological man
disappeared
would the world become more peaceful
why would you have to ration food
and why wouldn't the loss of all men on
the planet keep women from reproducing
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all men disappeared
i'd like to think that a world without
men would be the end of the human race
sadly we're not as important as we
sometimes think we are
and women might not even need us for
reproduction
some female animals can give birth by
themselves
it's called parthenogenesis and it's
common in sharks and lizards
these virgin births only happen when
there are no males in the female's
vicinity so how soon could human females
develop parthenogenesis
let me get back to human reproduction
without men in a moment because before
women could try to reproduce without men
they'd have to work hard to avoid the
total collapse of society
yeah without men the world would lose
about half its population and workforce
it would be up to the women to fill
traditionally male jobs
could they
now i believe 100 in a woman's ability
to do any job that a man can do but
women are still underrepresented in some
crucial jobs
that means they wouldn't have the
training to take over some male
dominated positions right away
like only 3.5 percent of firefighters
are women
fire season would get pretty bad
and of all the aircraft pilots and
flight engineers in the world only 5.2
percent are women
so plane travel would become rare and
expensive
and since only about 37
of physicians and surgeons are women
there'd be long wait times for surgeries
luckily there would still be plenty of
nurses
but the biggest hurdle the all-female
world would have to overcome
is that they'd only have 25
of our farmers left
food would become more expensive and
harder to find rationing would be
necessary for the first couple of years
eventually after years of training
changing jobs and restructuring the
world women would get a handle on things
and a new era of world peace would begin
or would it
would no men mean
no violence
well according to some scientists men
are more aggressive than women because
of their dna
if this is true then our hypothetical
world with only females
would be more peaceful
but others argue that men are more
violent because of culture societal
roles and gender inequality
if this is the case
women would have just as much potential
for violence as men do
maybe we could look at bonobo apes to
answer this question
these apes share almost 99
of their dna with us
females are the leaders in bonobo groups
and it turns out that they're a much
more peaceful lot than the chimpanzee
groups led by males
but if two different groups of bonobos
meet they fight viciously
so maybe the world wouldn't be all peace
and love with only a female population
at least militaries around the world
would be a lot smaller
the united states would have just
14.4 percent of its military left
north korea on the other hand would
dominate about 40 percent of its
military is female
it seems that women could do all right
without men but
what about reproduction
they couldn't do that by themselves
could they
well it wouldn't happen right away
first women would get pregnant by using
whatever's left in sperm banks
that would give them time to develop
ways to reproduce without men
in japan scientists successfully
converted the stem cells from a female
mouse into sperm cells those sperm cells
then impregnated another female mouse
now humans are much more complex than
mice so it would take a lot more
experimentation to perfect this
technology for human use
but if the women of the world perfected
this technology
babies could be born from two females
and because women would be partnering up
to produce offspring you could see a
return to a quote-unquote traditional
family structure
[Music]
now it would be a different story if all
men except for one disappeared
if you were the only man left in this
amazonian world
what would happen to you
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you